[Music]  from the very beginning of hillsdale our  commitment has been to develop the minds  and improve the hearts of our students  we believe that the ultimate aim of  education is to produce  true liberty of the mind and the soul  this aim requires us to pursue moral  virtue with the same rigor as  intellectual virtue  this is why every student at hillsdale  commits themselves to the honor code  this code isn't a list of rules or do's  and don'ts  it's a calling to a greater way to live  a hillsdale college student is honorable  in conduct  honest in word indeed dutiful in study  and service  and respectful of the rights of others  through  education the student rises to  self-government  this code is a commitment of one's heart  and mind to the highest moral character  to those things that are the most good  true  and beautiful